well how's it going lou um it's going
really well
i'm uh upstate new york i went for a
hike this morning
trying to stay in shape and fight off
those coveted curves
well let's dive right into what's
happening on roni right now where we
left off
ramona broke the fourth wall no
it quit the show right done
[Music]
break reduction here we're done
done did she threaten to quit the show
she
missed that i missed that yeah
um yeah ramona was like
she was embarrassed by leah's behavior
ramona you know
really judges i think leah more harshly
than she does
sonia i think she's used to sonya's
antics
um and with leah she feels like the
mother
figure and is always giving her advice
and thought her
behavior was um
was not classy
uh what's been really interesting about
this year in bravo is we've kind of seen
the fourth wall breaking happen a lot
um and make it to tv has ramona tried to
control stuff before
well sure i mean there's been i remember
in when we were filming and i think the
turks and
cape cod there was a moment where sonia
was just
not well and you know cameras down
camera's down you know so this
is not the first time but why do you
think ramona has such an issue with leah
is it just because she's the new girl
and she's
giving her a hard time or well i think
that
you know she judges liam more harshly
than she does the other
she's new given her hard time you know
feels
like she's a mother figure so uh it
feels like she should chime in on her
behavior
it seems like we might even reach a
point where ramona
crosses a line i found out she's bipolar
and she's on medication you cannot mix
alcohol with meds it makes you act
not responsible do you think she crossed
the line you know ramona loves to weigh
in
on leo way too much and you'll have to
see
what happens coming up in the next
episodes
you guys are headed to mexico in the
next few episodes
what can you tell me about this trip
it's always memorable when
the new york ladies head anywhere
especially mexico
i know right god knows i have my history
in mexico
it's a great trip we're just you know
having a great time and
you know and of course there's the drama
that goes on and it's
you know there's more stuff with jorinda
there's more stuff with ramona
so it's very i'm really looking forward
to watching it myself because
i haven't seen it yet either any
encounters with bushes this time around
no but there is encounters with men so
um
you know it's not a trip without having
an encounter with a man
remember the pirate i never the
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
from the look-aheads that we've seen
that ramona is going to try
and stage some sort of anger management
intervention with dorinda
can you look in the mirror please look
in the mirror sorry
why does she do this it's kind of an
ongoing issue and ramona wants to nip it
in the butt and get to the bottom of it
so
um so she's trying to approach it in the
best possible way and
i don't know if it's gonna actually turn
out the best possible way for
ramona or dorinda yeah we we kind of
know that when you approach dorinda
about stuff
like this it usually goes the opposite
way uh
that maybe the person is intending and
you've obviously had your own issues
with dorinda
most recently in this year's berkshires
trip
with your hands you know everything you
know what no you don't know everything
no you don't
watch yourself oh you're drunk and full
you have a mug shot of your drunkenness
why do you think she always brings it
back to the mug shot with you why does
she
take it to that place you know i um i
i don't know i just know that it doesn't
feel good
and it's not right and i think that for
her to keep bringing that
up it's just you know it's like sucker
punching somebody
i think something interesting this
season was your relationship with
alcohol and figuring out what that looks
like in a
kind of post um arrest
world talk to me about making the
decision to
not only start drinking again but to
also do it on tv
you know listen uh on the show there's a
lot of drinking going on you know it's
it's about vacations and parties and you
know
so it's really hard to avoid and you
know
i don't want to make it a thing you know
i don't want it to define who i
am for two years i spent on probation
you know
not being able to drink and you know
there's nothing worse than somebody
saying to you you cannot have one drink
otherwise you're going to jail i mean
that's a very difficult way to live
now i decided you know if i'm going to
do another season maybe i drink maybe i
won't
i'm all for people deciding uh what
they'd like to do with their own lives
and i take it day by day
i want to take it back to uh the cabaret
fight with sonia
i never want to see her in my show she's
not coming into my show she's worthless
you're worthless so you're not coming to
my show i'd never want to see you into
my show you're not coming into my show
ever how do you feel about how it looked
on tv well listen i personally i you
know
i learned from watching myself and i
thought oh my god i
you know if i just drank too much i wish
i could have handled it differently
um and really got the point across but
in retrospect i i could have handled it
better and i'm glad to have that
opportunity
though to see myself and say okay that's
not happening again
and and you will not see me um
get that plastered this season so i'm
happy to say
that's good yeah that was one night i
just kind of went off the rails a little
bit
it happens it happens to the best of us
yeah i have seen the some of the fan
conversation online though is that this
season does seem very fueled by alcohol
more than
any season we've seen before um what do
you think about that does something need
to change within this group to
i think that definitely i think that a
lot of the what's going on is fueled by
alcohol
and i think that you know it's time to
check in with yourself
i'm not giving any advice to anybody and
on those terms because you know
that's gonna fall flat for me and i
certainly don't like to judge people and
they're drinking because i'm you know no
one to
to judge but i feel like that we could
that we could definitely reel in it on
the drinking part uh drinking a side
where do you think the group goes
after this season is it time for a
shake-up should we introduce some new
ladies
what do you think you know tinsley's now
gone so
i'm sure there's gonna be someone
introduced to the show for the new
season
and you know i just feel like we need to
go somewhere
to start off the season you know let's
get out of dodge you know we've been
here for four or five months now
right but there's got to be a place
where we can go where we can just get
away
from our you know everyday lives and
um and just you know relax
and and and and you know
reconnect yeah reconnect reset a little
bit
reconnect reset i think a trip at the
very beginning of the season would be
the perfect remedy
i like this idea luanne yeah right i
mean
we know that we always go on a trip at
the end of the season right right
i like flipping the script yeah i like
flipping the script too
i have seen some of your cast members
have judged how ramona has behaved
during this pandemic a little bit it
seems like
at least leah and dorinda are kind of
done with ramona at this point with how
she's behaved how do you feel about
ramona
i don't know exactly what she was up to
but
um but let's put it this way she was a
little bit more risque than most people
were at that time
ramona could have been more careful
especially you know she has to be around
us you know coming up soon so right
so she better be wearing a mask so yeah
you're gearing up for a reunion
you know i'm hoping that we're all going
to be together in studio
and that's going to pan out um you just
never know because what
what's happening in the world you know
things can change on a regular basis
so right now the plan is to do it in
person that's the plan
that's exciting because we haven't had
one of those a little bit i don't know
well
who
um what's the number one question or
thing you want to address this time
around
um well at this point you know let's
talk about the cabaret thing you know my
show
started out very small in new york at 54
below i had a lot of people on the show
a lot of people would pay and i wasn't
making money in the beginning so
you know uh and broadway is scale sonia
you know doesn't really come up and
perform she just comes up and says hello
and basically
you know did a little dance with me and
then took off her dress
so you know maybe i should have taken
spent more on
her trip yeah maybe there's a
you needed to pay a different that's a
different level right that's a different
scale it's a different skill set
it's a stripper scale i do have to ask
because it seems every week when the
show is on
my twitter feed is inundated with people
just tweeting at bethany being like come
back come back come back
would you want to see bethany come back
or do you like the vibe without her i
don't think that bethany would come back
to the show
in any case but listen bring it on
girlfriend you know i've been dealing
with bethany for years and i'm like her
go-to
when it comes to finding someone to spar
with put up your dukes
uh yeah no she's kind of said as much
too and i think the show's bigger than
any one person and i kind of like
watching the evolution of the group over
time
i gotta tell you i mean you know i don't
think leah replaced her because lily is
a totally different person
but i think it's one of our best seasons
yet it's just like a madness every week
like it's
there's not really a through storyline
of what's happening but each episode is
you could re-watch it over and over
again it's like a very watchable season
and something that's actually been fun
to watch is you guys filmed your at home
confessionals
and your first one people took a lot of
notice of a portrait you had
sitting on a bookshelf what's the story
behind that picture of yourself that was
on that bookshelf
that was you know that's an old modeling
picture of mine
from uh when i first started modeling in
new york
so i'm talking like late 80s uh
and it actually came from
a photographer who did my very first
photo shoot in new york so
that's got a lot of history of that
photograph it did look like they gave
you a little bit of an upgrade on your
setup for a second round of
confessionals because this last week we
was like oh we're back kind of to what
we know
confessionals to be we're learning as we
go along because you know we
initially had to they walked us through
setting up
everything on our own i did an interview
okay on my own i did a couple but the
last interview that i did
um i forgot to press go no
so i'm there after two hours in here and
makeup
setting up the shot and bleeding my
heart out to the camera
for two hours more i'm talking five
hours
was not recorded i mean i was i could
not believe it
all of all of that talking and energy
and
you know i can't believe she said that
and what and and then i
go to hit off and it starts recording
never recorded
bryce i tell you i was anyway we
we had to get it the next day so i had
to do it all over again
my goodness well what what you
were able to make happen has been great
tv it's been such a fun season to watch
i'm excited to see this backpack i hope
you do get to be in person for the
reunion because i think the energy of an
in-person reunion is yeah
10 times better than virtual i agree
anything else you want to say about the
last few episodes we're going to get
this year
you know what it's just it just gets
better and better so
enjoy season 12 darling you're gonna
love it